c'est important
qui de nous re cherche à être mal non
franchement on préfère tous être bien
plus tôt que mal qu'elle bien-être c'est
quoi eh ben c'est bien dans sa peau dans
son corps sa tête dans sa vie avec sa
famille avec ses amis et quand on n'est
pas bien qu'on ait ralenti à cause d'une
migraine dindo qui fait mal ou une autre
partie du corps qui est douloureux et
bassal enfin on n'est pas bien s'étaient
pas prendre le nom pour qu'on avance on
a plein de choses à faire
y a pas le temps ou à la place d'avoir
mal quelque part
alors un petit as kevin un anti douleur
ou quelques vitamines et ça repart et
puis ce corps qui fonctionne pas comme
on voudrait c'est agaçant ce trop plein
de sensibilité qui nous déstabilise
vis-à-vis de certaines personnes ou
certaines situations ça vous parle
et bien si de ce corps que je souhaite
vous parler notre corps changer le
regard sur nous mêmes et écouter ce fait
notre corps peut dire car il nous parle
tous les jours et nous on exporte nous
le faire à travers différents
traitements ou comportements et on
continuera lancé alors bien sûr on râle
d'être ralenti on perd la frayeur ce
corps qui fonctionne pas comme on
voudrait mais on les fout toujours port
jusqu'au jour où ce corps eh ben il en a
marre pas être entendus alors il décide
de faire un stop ses mains un doigt
contre une cheville qu'on laisse une
angine une sciatique ou tout autre mais
dit wow incident qui vous empêche de
continuer son même rythme alors vous
allez voter
pourquoi ça vous arrive à vous et
maintenant parce que ça tombe mal c'est
vrai nom d'omar raddad et vous allez
commencer à prendre soin de vous
vous allez chez le médecin pour
retrouver la santé que vous avez perdu
alors que dans de nombreux autres pays
c'est au contraire eux qui prennent soin
d'eux de leur bien-être pour rester en
bonne santé et si on savait tout ça et
pour l'avé oublié parce que j'en ai
plein d'eau ras la casquette chez à côté
de mes pompes
toutes ces expressions qu'on utilise
sont plus qu'honnête leur raison d'être
raison d'être bien-être c'est quoi ce
être un être humain un être vivant c'est
quoi au juste
et bien la notion dû être c'est ce que
nous avons oublié et que c'est aux
traditions ont su se rappeler le âtre
c'est en tout indissociable
nous notre éducation à nous à formater
dans une notion de séparation
nous nous séparons notre corps de nos
émotions et de nos pensées
alors que le hêtre est un tout
indissociable
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre les
différentes cultures dont nous inspirons
au pratiquer le yoga le tchi kong la
méditation
ils voient tous les choses en terme de
circulation d'énergie
cette énergie elle est alimentée par une
énergie comme une énergie de vie qu'elle
s'appelle anna 6 esprit saint mana c'est
la même énergie
c'est une énergie et lorsque notre corps
une perle
c'est tant d'énergie à l'énergie on peut
la voir comment on peut la voir comme
l'eau d'une rivière qui s'écoule dans
notre corps s'il ya des troncs d'arbres
ou des pierres qui encombrent la rivière
lot à l'eau s'accumule et à certains
endroits et pied va se raréfier à
d'autres pour autant l'on va continuer
de notre corps c'est pareil une émotion
ou une pensée bloc en nous cela va
perturber la fluidité de l'énergie en
nous ça va créer un dysfonctionnement au
même titre qu avant la rivière et alors
ça va se transformer en quoi va d'abord
en émotions puis une douleur pouvant
aller jusqu'à la maladie si on ne pense
pas à retirer les pianos la rivière
écoutez ce que notre chorale dire c'est
maintenir une bonne circulation
d'énergie dans notre corps j'aime
beaucoup la citation de gandhi qui vit
grand soin de ton corps pour que ton âme
et envie d'y rester
quand soin de ton corps pour que ton âme
notre corps est le prolongement de notre
âme notre mal-être nos douleurs
physiques non maladie sont des messages
de notre âme pour nous dire que quelque
chose ne va pas dans notre vie c'est une
invitation à un changement d'attitude
deux postures de comportement pour
équilibrer les choses dans votre vie je
vous donne un exemple est-ce qu'il vous
est déjà arrivé de vous blesser
vous êtes en train de couper quelque
chose avec un couteau
vous vous dites il faut que je fasse
attention sinon j'ai coupé votre couteau
ou continuer à obtenir la même manière
et vous nous coupez et vous vous dites
je le savais ou alors pourquoi c'est
toujours la dernière descente de ski on
tombe tous les mac vous êtes déjà
demandé vous avez passé une super
journée ça s'est bien passé pour vous
c'était génial
vous savez que vous en avez assez faible
t'es bon mais bon faut bien amortir
forfait filet copains qui sont avec nous
sont pas fatigués mais il n'y a pas de
raisons tu peux bien faire une pige en
fait une des pistes on habille je me
blesse et puis beaucoup passé la
dernière descente de la journée
un dernier petit exemple la personne tu
sors je connaissais plein des comme ça
j'en fais trop j'en fais trop chaude et
profonde jamais faudrait lever le pied
j'en fais trop j'en fais trop fougères
le pied fait plus continuer à en faire
trop
une pièce là qui ont atteint marche et
du coup c'est la cheville qui cède à
baron cohen the bay qui on va enfin
beaucoup moins pourquoi on ne s'écoute
pas que faisons nous donc nous avons mal
quelque part on prend un antidouleur
c'est ça le problème chine lorsqu'on est
triste malheureux mon manque de joie
eh ben on se dit oh dépression et on
prend des antidépresseurs
on n'arrive pas à dormir dans voir
prendre des somnifères
on est fatigué c'est un petit peu
difficile
allez on rajoute de trois cafés à la
nouvelle mutuelle et puis c'est bon ça
repart c'est bien sachez lorsque quelque
chose nous empêchent de fonctionner
comme on en a l'habitude
au lieu de se dire qu'il ya quelque
chose qui cloche et d'aller regarder si
elle tient dans la rivière et banon
continue comme si de rien n'était
jusqu'au jour où le corps à force de
tirer dessus
eh ben ils cèdent et on tombe malade et
pour tonton balade et pourrait à terme
hélas hélas pour eux à se poser des
questions c'est là qu'on commence à
regarder la vie différemment et à
s'ouvrir à une autre vision de la vie
alors moi j'aimerais vous éviter ça donc
j'aimerais que vous n'attendiez pas que
votre corps cède pour vous commenciez à
changer votre regard sur votre vie alors
comment maintenir l'harmonie comment
prendre soin de son corps pour que notre
âme et envie d'y rester
moi mon domaine c'est le massage
et dans le passage je retrouve une
philosophie commune que toutes les
énergies donc à travers un massage on va
pouvoir faire ce librement circuler
l'énergie dans le corps et ainsi libérer
les tensions nerveuses ou émotionnelle
tous les massages ancestraux l'épée dont
je vous parlais vite à rétablir
l'harmonie dans le corps dans l'homme et
dans l'esprit c'est un qui la première
chose que je demande à mes élèves c'est
de s'aligner avant même de toucher la
personne à massy pourquoi parce que la
qualité de ce qui les habite va se
sentir dans leurs clichés
donc s'ils sont contrariés pour une
raison x ou y
leur massage va être à l'image de ceux
qui les habitent
le massage est à l'image de ce dont je
ne parle unités ou séparation à ma soeur
soit une base de manière mécanique
parce que pour lui tout n'est que
matière soit un master i mas avec une
main en présence dans le respect de la
personne qui va masse et c'est cette
présence
moi qui m'est précieuse de transmettre
la magie du massage c'est soit on compte
qu'on n'est pas que matière s'est
réalisée pour neil score cette âme cet
esprit en unités essais réalisés donc
que les personnes ou les situations qui
nous entourent ont une répercussion sur
nous et nous sur elle et donc c'est une
qualité deux êtres qui est valable dans
toutes les situations de lui
docu moi j'ai envie de vous dire
d'arrêter de se séparer votre corps de
vos amis de vos émotions
j'ai envie de vous faire réaliser que
c'est un tout c'est les gens qui nous
entourent ce les gens avec qui l'on a
baissé avec nous mêmes et c'est la
qualité de ce qu'on aime on va pouvoir
transmettre autour de nous donc moi j'ai
juste envie de vous dire cesser de
penser que c'est égoïste de penser à soi
de s'occuper de soi c'est tout le
contraire en prenant soin de vous en
assurant votre bien-être votre arme au
nez vous êtes en paix avec vous même si
vous écoutez votre âme à travers votre
corps vous éviterez de tomber malade
avant de redresser la situation changer
de regard sur vous même
écoutez ce que votre âme à vous dire
appuyez votre corps comme un ami comme
un allié qui vous aide à bien vivre à
être en joie être en paix c'est grâce à
lui que vous avancez on la vit il est le
véhicule de votre être
il est le fidèle baromètre de votre état
d'âme
souvenez vous vous rayonnez de qui vous
êtes
merci
[Applaudissements]